Candid truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. If you guys
haven't been paying attention, prophecy
is unfolding right before our very eyes.
Did you not hear about Trump's new
Genesis mission? Genesis mission sounds
so biblical and beautiful, right? We
have talked about this for a while. If
you haven't went back and checked out
our videos about Trump unrolling out
Stargate AI surveillance. That was a
year ago.
Over a year ago,
the UN had this thing where they were
Ever while everyone's distracted, I
didn't vote on it, you didn't vote on
it, but they voted in that they wanted
total AI governance by 2030, I think.
You got to go watch the video and people
were telling me they're like, no, you're
you're misinterpreting this. This is
talking about governing AI, not AI
governing us. That's not what I was
reading in the report. And sure enough,
here we are, you know, a year ago at the
beginning of this year or at the end of
last year, Trump had these tech guys
come on and he said, I want you guys to
tell them about the the new thing and
and they were like, yeah, it's AI
total AI surveillance on a global scale
and they were saying things like, people
will behave when they are being
surveillanced 24/7.
This is a total dystopian world and all
those Trumpers out there who thought
they were voting for Trump because he
was going to be our Messiah. He was
going to overthrow the New World Order
and save the day. We've been saying from
the very beginning, they are two wings
of the same bird. They're all puppets.
Don't even think that your vote counts.
All right, if that didn't trigger
anybody, stay with me, please.
I want to show you guys this because
this is what's up right now. This is on
the White House website right here and
it says launching the Genesis mission.
The Genesis mission.
First off, I want you to notice that
seal that's above right there.
This is the seal.
To me, it looks totally like a goat head
pentagram, inverted pentagram. There's a
lot of symbolism in here. This is the
Phoenix rising from the ashes. This is
the eagle that goes back to Rome.
There's 13 arrows. All this stuff is
symbolic, but when you add these numbers
together, these people are numerical
freaks. They're astrological,
numerical, everything predictive
programming and when you add four and
five, you get nine and when you add four
and seven, you get 11. So, right at the
top, you have 911. If you haven't seen
the video, go back and watch the video
that says the deception is greater than
we thought or something along those
lines. It shows Trump with a ear patch
and a golden calf. That thing blew my
mind. As God was helping me put together
the presentation breaking down
numerology, why those towers were
literally built to be taken down. Two
towers become one, the One World Tower.
It was all planned from the very
beginning. 911. It's all about
burn and rebuild.
Phoenix rising out of the ashes. That's
what 911 means if you didn't know. Now,
check this out on the website.
This is the actual This is the actual
White House website
and I'm not going to read all this. You
know, I got
I got a a summarized version
on the keynotes, but this is the real
whitehouse.gov.
Check that out.
Here is the breakdown of what the
Genesis mission is. It says the US
government through Department of Energy
and the central government data
apparatus is launching a nationwide
unified AI platform. Did you catch that?
A nationwide
unified AI platform.
Put that in your memory because we're
going to talk more about this
singularity movement to where once
singularity happens, there's no escape,
all right? Using federal
data sets, supercomputers, national
labs, research institutions and private
sector partners to accelerate scientific
discovery. The plan, train powerful
scientific foundation models, create AI
agents that can test hypotheses,
automate research workflows, simulate
experiments, effectively letting AI
direct and accelerate research in all
major domains, energy including nuclear
and fusion. Nuclear, pay attention to
that word, nuclear,
biotech, materials, quantum computing,
quantum,
microelectronics manufacturing, the
works. The public rationale, solve the
most challenging problems of the
century, boost US scientific and
technological dominance, secure energy
dominance, strengthen national security.
National security. We're being
imprisoned securely in this nation
and get maximum return on decades of R&D
investments. All right, guys, you got to
think outside the box. You cannot just
swallow everything these elitist wicked
people
These are puppets of Satan. They are not
They don't have your best interest,
okay? When they talk about national
security, yeah, it's not what you think
it is.
Implementation roadmap, build the
infrastructure. Supercomputers,
cloud-based AI compute, data access
framework, secure environment.
Integrate data from federal labs plus
academia plus
industry, then deploy AI
based experimentation,
automated labs, robotics,
manufacturing and simulations, okay?
That was a mouthful, guys, but basically
what we see here is nuclear,
quantum physics,
national security
and AI robots, all right? Think about
all that together. Where is this headed?
Somewhere good? Do you Do you think that
this is somewhere good?
I don't I don't believe it is.
There was a movie I used to be a huge
fan of the Terminator saga. I loved
every movie. I watched them all
except for Dark Fate. By that time, I
was done with these movies. But, do you
see anything interesting on this poster?
Well, the name of the movie is literally
Genesis. Terminator Genesis. Why is it
called Genesis? We're going to look into
that. And what is the slogan?
New mission,
new fate. Put them together, what do you
get? Genesis mission. Right?
Genesis mission. Launching Genesis
mission.
Look, we know predictive programming is
real. We've seen it over and over and
over again, right? This is not some
fluke accident.
I actually did a video. I might have it
pulled up here. I did my first ever
Little Light movie breakdown was
actually on
Terminator, on the Terminator saga. And
if you've never really looked at it and
broke it down, basically, if you watch
just the first movie, there's a bad guy,
he's the Terminator, there's the good
guy, he's John Connor or initials JC
like Jesus Christ. He was a supernatural
birth because his dad was a time
traveler. He He goes back in time to
defeat Satan and if you watch just movie
part one, besides all the nudity and the
gore and all that stuff, it's basically
like a biblical theme like good destroys
evil.
But, that's how Satan lures you in,
right? He always makes episode one,
movie one, season one seem to have a
good plot and when you get sucked in,
then the gnostic inverted gospel comes
out. The Luciferian gospel comes out.
So, by part two, what happens? Is
Terminator still the bad guy? No.
Terminator says, come with me if you
want to live and the bad guy is the cop
or the law enforcer, which is God. And
there's so many things that are deep in
there, but when you get to Terminator
Genesis,
by the time you get to Terminator
Genesis, the whole inverted gospel is
flipped because John Connor, who in one
scene even has a hole in his hand,
he gets infected with a virus. He
becomes the bad guy. Terminator, who is
supposed to be the bad guy, Terminator,
destroys John Connor, JC or Jesus
Christ, destroys him in a kamikaze act
and then a door bust open and it's a
bright light and you see a silhouette of
Terminator and Sarah Connor runs and
embraces him just like Mary meeting
Jesus at the tomb on resurrection day
because he just kamikaze. Now, he's
resurrected and at the end of the movie,
it shows
Kyle,
Sarah and no longer John Connor. He
doesn't exist anymore. Jesus Christ is
gone. JC is gone and now Terminator.
Pop.
It's It's John It's
Sarah Connor,
Kyle
and Terminator. That's who's left. John
Connor has been defeated, deleted and
the exit monologue is this whole thing
about
now we know that one road has become
many and the future is not set and all
this gnostic
garbage. All right, go check that video
out. That I That was seven years ago,
eight years ago. The Terminator
The Terminator breakdown on Little Light
Studios.
All right, so we see that this is a
gnostic movie. It's got predictive
programming all in it and I'm going to
show you just a short clip of how
they're promoting this Genesis mission
thing as such a a good thing. Like this
is the official website, US Department
of Energy. Check this out. Genesis
mission will transform how science is
done in America.
Uniting our brightest minds, most
powerful computers, and vast scientific
data into one living system for
discovery.
Built on artificial intelligence and
quantum computing, it will radically
redefine the scale, speed, and purpose
of scientific progress in America.
This is the work that will define our
generation's legacy.
A new revolution begins.
One guided not by competition alone, but
by curiosity, imagination,
and the belief that discovery
is the truest form of progress.
All right, so there was stuff all in
there, all right? So much like
uh
fake space, rockets, eyeball symbolism.
All of it was in there. You guys might
not be on the same page as me with some
of that, but this is all propaganda.
This is saying, "Oh, look how beautiful
this new AI thing is going to be."
Basically, in this movie
um or in the movie saga, there's
something called Skynet. Skynet is
basically an AI surveillance technology,
just like Stargate, what we're hearing
about from Trump.
But they knew that it was going to go
rogue, that it realized AI woke up,
became sentient, and realized that
humans were the pest on the Earth. They
were the cause of all the problems, so
it decided to launch all the nukes and
destroy humanity.
So,
instead, they came out with this Genesis
operating system that everybody's so
excited about. It was a Trojan horse. It
was a Trojan horse that was Skynet.
Secretly inside of this Genesis
operating system, it is, again, Skynet.
They thought they defeated it, but no,
it's coming. And every They said a
billion people have signed up for this,
and they're waiting, and they're
watching, and they're watching this
countdown. But listen to the what the
words are from this speaker behind the
pulpit. Check this out.
Tomorrow, the waiting is over.
When that countdown hits zero,
Cyberdyne will revolutionize technology
with the ultimate
>> killer app, Genesis. And I'm here to
tell you that
our pre-orders as of this afternoon have
reached 1 billion users.
Yeah.
We are creating the dawn of a new age,
where every single piece of technology
you own will be seamlessly linked.
All right, there was two important
things I want you to
remember from this.
We are creating the dawn of a new age,
and
every single piece of technology you own
will be seamlessly linked to Genesis.
And everybody loves it. They think it's
a great idea because this is how the
stuff gets implemented into law, is it's
always through convenience, right? Or
through fear of safety. Like when 9/11
happened, it was the Patriot Act. We're
going to sign this Patriot Act, and we
can tap all your phones, and we can pat
you down everywhere at the TSA. And
people are like, "Good. Please protect
us. We're scared." So fear uh pushes
people into surrendering their freedoms.
Then there's also the
convenience aspect. So, you know, we we
used to have corded phones, and we went
to cordless phones. You had a beeper,
and you had a home computer, and TV at
home, and now it's all in one convenient
device. We can watch We can call on it.
I can call, I can text, I can uh surf
the web, I can watch things on it. It's
so convenient. We know it's listening to
everything we say. We know that it's
watching us. We've seen all the uh
Dateline and NBC and all these things
where they're literally proving these
things watch you and listen to you 24/7.
And we're like, "You know what? I can't
live without my phone. It's convenient."
So we allow ourselves to be tapped, and
myself included in this, these This is a
powerful tool that I can do what I'm
doing right now on it, okay?
It's convenient.
It is our demise.
But this is what's coming, singularity,
where every device you have is connected
to one. What did the UK say?
The UK said, "You will, and we're going
to give it to you for free, but you're
going to get a digital ID, or else you
will not work." You know what digital ID
does? It connects everything that you
own. Your home, your electricity, your
water, your car insurance, everything is
connected to one identification. See,
right now, you can uh you know, you can
pay for your bill with this card, you
can use this email over here, you can
use a different card over here. There's
all kinds of ways to pay for your
appliances
and insurances and all these things. But
when the universal identification comes,
the the digital ID comes,
everything's going to be linked in. So
now you're driving your car, your smart
car, because everything's smart, right?
You You'll own nothing, and you'll like
it. You're driving your gray Tesla like
everyone else, because it's not really
yours, you're borrowing it. And it it
knows who you are because it's scanning
your face the whole time, and you go a
little bit over the speed limit, and
boop.
Well, you you didn't get to go to court
or fight the ticket or anything. The
money comes right out of your bank
account.
All right? Um social credit score
system.
I'm going to show you the clip.
Um Elon is saying that AI is going to
take over so many jobs that we're going
to have to figure out some kind of new
universal credit system because there's
not going to be any jobs. So we have to
come up with some kind of credit system.
How do you think that credit system is
going to work? Well, when you read the
Book of Revelation, it's all about
worship. You must worship according to
this way. So, what I predict and what I
see happening in China, who are already
They are the guinea pigs for this social
credit score system. They have public
shaming, and they have punishment. Like
if you cro- if you uh jaywalk, oh well,
you lose some of your credit score.
And if you, you know, litter, well, they
show you on screens all around the city,
and your credit score goes down. So how
do you get your credit score up? You
have to do morally good, kind acts.
Well, who sets those rules?
Well, it it's going to be the powers
that be.
And so, when the mark of the beast
comes, when the one world religion
comes, there's going to be the universal
coexist church, where everybody goes.
And guess what? You know, that When you
go there every Sunday, you're going to
get a really good credit score. You know
what? If you go to church every Sunday
at the Universal Church, it's teaching
you how to not be so judgmental. It's
teaching you how to be accepting of
others and loving of others and
tolerance. It's going to teach you how
to be a good, moral, tolerant, coexist
person. And if you go there,
you're going to be good for the week.
Every You'll be able to buy groceries,
you'll be able to pay all your bills. If
you just go to the Universal Church,
your life will be so much simpler. Why
are you fighting this?
See, it's going to At first, it's going
to be kind of a voluntary thing, like
"Oh, well, you didn't go. Well, life's
going to be really hard for you." But
then the Bible says that it will be
punishable by death. If you do not
worship according to the beast system,
you will be punished to death.
That's where I think all this is going.
Now check out
Elon Musk in this video where he's
talking about um AI is going to take
over so many jobs that work's going to
be optional.
It'll be like uh playing sports or video
game or something like that. If you want
to work, uh you know, in the same way
like you can you can go to the store and
just buy some vegetables, or you could
grow vegetables in your backyard. It's
much harder to grow vegetables
vegetables in your backyard, but some
people still do it because they like
growing growing vegetables.
Um that will be what work is like,
optional. If you go out long enough,
assuming there's a continued im-
improvement in AI and robotics, which
this seems likely,
the money will will will stop being
relevant at some point in the future. I
believe he's onto something. I believe
he knows what he's talking about here.
Um if you haven't seen this video, The
Deception Is Stronger Than You Think.
This is the one I was just
recommending you guys watch. This thing
is still one of my top favorite videos
uh that we did on our channel. Go check
it out. It's called The Deception Is
Stronger Than You Think. But even back
then, when was this? November 19th,
2024,
we were talking about this stuff, and
here is what Elon was saying back then,
a year ago. There will be fewer and
fewer jobs that a robot cannot do
better. What to do about mass
unemployment? This is going to be a
massive social challenge. And I I think
ultimately we will have to have some
kind of universal basic income. I don't
think we're going to have a choice.
Universal basic income.
>> Universal basic income. I think it's
going to be necessary. So it's mean that
unemployed people will be paid across
the globe. Yeah. Because there is no
job. Machine, robot is taking over. Th-
These are not uh things that I think
that I wish would happen. These are
things simply things that I think
probably will happen. If my assessment
is correct, and they probably will
happen, then we need to say, "What are
we going to do about it?"
And I think some kind of a universal
basic income is going to be necessary.
The output of goods and services will be
extremely high. Um so with automation,
there will come abundance.
Almost everything will get
very cheap. I think we'll just end up
doing
universal basic income. It's going to be
necessary. The the harder challenge,
much harder challenge is
how do people then have meaning? Like a
lot of people they derive their meaning
from their employment. So if you're not
needed, if there's not a need for your
labor, how do you what's the meaning? Do
you do you have meaning? Do you feel
useless? These are much That's a much
harder problem to deal with.
Okay, so he's talking about AI is going
to take Look at this. You might think
this is far-fetched. Already AI has
taken over uh
translation. If you're a translator,
your job's gone. Narration, your job's
gone.
A lot of artists, people don't even pay
artists anymore because they got AI art.
Your job's gone. Musicians, you can you
can use Suno and make a a beat, make a
song with music, everything. Jobs gone.
Movies, jobs gone.
Um you know, cash registers, we ring up
our own stuff, right? Uber drivers,
everything's going to be self-driving
cars very, very soon. There's going to
be a lot of jobs that are going to be
gone. I mean, there's
accounting because of ChatGPT and things
like this, you don't need certain
people. I don't need a lawyer. I don't
need a accountant. I can I can put all
this stuff in ChatGPT and it can do it
for me.
Right? So there's a lot of people whose
jobs are going to be gone. And so we
have to come up with some kind of
universal basic income. This was another
video. If you haven't checked this out
on our channel, it's called Stargate AI
Surveillance Will Make You Behave. This
came out 10 months ago, January 29th,
2025.
And when I was watching this,
actually I was putting this together and
I didn't even notice what was on the
screen. It's talking about
you It's talking about the social credit
score system in China. And look at
what's on the screen. Look at what this
technology is called. This technology is
AI surveillance, face tracking, all this
stuff. And look at what it's called.
Something that makes
>> a huge fan of Terminator. Look at this.
Skynet?
Oh my goodness. You You see that on
screen.
This was on the news.
Like in China, this is the system
they're using literally called Skynet.
If that doesn't mean anything to you,
that's exactly what it was called in
Terminator. The AI governance
the AI world governance was called
Skynet. We already have it. Talk about
predictive programming. This stuff is
already here.
Remember what we just talked about in
this previous slide, he was saying, "We
are creating the dawn of a new age." The
dawn of a new age, all right?
What did Trump say? This was January of
this year.
With the promise of a golden age, a
second Trump era begins. Look at what
Trump Look at the caption. A golden age
of America begins right now. Here he is
saying it.
The golden age of America begins right
now.
What does that mean, the golden age?
This will truly be the golden age of
America. That's what we have to know.
All right, when you look this up, the
golden age is synonymous with
the dawn of a new age, which is exactly
what the movie said. The movie said that
this
Genesis
literally the same the same name that
Trump has made this thing. I don't know
whoever named it.
The same name for this AI surveillance
technology worldwide singularity thing
they announced that this is going to be
the dawn of a new age.
So the golden age is a past or future
era of historical perfection
prosperity and harmony.
It is the ideal benchmark. That's what
Trump was saying, the golden age. What
is the dawn of a new age? The beginning
or transition point into a new era often
marked by significant change or a break
from the past. That's where we're going.
Genesis means beginning.
That's what the book of Genesis means.
We're literally having a new beginning,
burning down the old order of things,
and rising up out of the ashes is the
new world order.
Just like all these cities that got
burnt down and what what got replaced
with them?
Smart cities. They're go They're
literally burning cities down and
replacing them with smart cities.
Now I asked, is the golden age the same
as dawn of the new age? And it said AI
on Google said, "Yes, the term golden
age is often conceptually connected with
the dawn of the new age, particularly in
prophetic, mythological, and
philosophical context, a golden age can
be seen as the fulfillment or
realization of the new era's potential."
That's where we're going. So
the movie said it. The movie predicted
it. The movie's announcing Genesis
an AI technology
that'll push people into a singularity
where all your devices are connected to
one. That's what he said. And he said
we're going to a dawn of a new age. And
Trump has been saying ever since he
talked about this Stargate technology
that we're going into a golden age. So I
asked what does the golden age mean to
Alice Bailey? According to Alice Bailey,
the golden age is a future period
characterized by the externalization of
the hierarchy where spiritual leaders or
hierarchy
would become outwardly visible to
humanity after 2025.
This event would coincide with a new era
of human evolution
ushering in a new world order based on
principles of goodwill, unity, and
spiritual understanding. Look, Google
When you ask Google things, it's the
least conspiratorial
answers. It's always sugarcoating
everything. This is straight facts
coming from her writings.
The externalization of the hierarchy,
this is the key concept in Bailey's work
describing a future time when the
spiritual hierarchy, which is usually
hidden, will make itself known to
humanity. What is happening right now?
Our military leaders around the world
are saying, "We communicate with
non-human intelligences." They're
telling us to our faces, "Yes, we do
communicate with interdimensional
beings." They are using this
terminology.
They're telling us the externalization
of the hierarchy is here.
They're just not showing us yet.
But this is a soft disclosure. It's been
happening for 5 years now.
Post-2025 time frame, Bailey predicted
this period of externalization would
begin sometime after 2025. We're at the
end of this year, guys.
Transformation of society
the golden age would involve a
significant shift in human consciousness
and the establishment of a new world
based on spiritual principles.
Okay, so when gold when Trump is saying
golden age and he's rolling out Genesis,
which means beginning, and it's going to
be this
singularity movement
and it's going to push us and shift us
into another state of consciousness.
Spiritual principles. Our Our military
are saying we communicate with
interdimensional beings.
Everything is coming to pass. Now I
asked
what did Helena Blavatsky say of the
golden age? According to Helena
Blavatsky, the golden age is a future
era, same thing, also called the age of
Maitreya that will follow a current Kali
Yuga or the dark age and be
characterized by spiritual and
intellectual
awakening, peace, and harmony. Ring a
bell? The Bible says peace and safety,
sudden destruction will come upon them.
It will be a time of greater spiritual
intellect intelligence. Greater
spiritual intelligence
and the reemergence of profound esoteric
knowledge.
Knowledge from the tree of knowledge,
the garden.
This age is not a return to a primitive
past, but a future evolution towards a
more spiritual conscious civilization.
It goes on and it says spirit Well,
these are the characteristics of the
golden age according to her. A spiritual
awakening. Humanity will achieve a
higher level of consciousness leading to
a greater spiritual understanding and
intuition. That's what I believe the
coexist one world religion will be all
about. It's going to be like the new
age. Oh, I Yes, I talked to Jesus every
day. He's one of my ascended masters and
Buddha and Confucius and we all just
coexist. Kumbaya.
Coexist. Harmony and peace. There will
be a disappearance of hatred and a
universal flow of love and compassion.
Reemergence of knowledge. Esoteric
knowledge, which was common in the past,
will become more accessible to humanity.
Wait a minute. A reemergence of
knowledge will become more accessible?
This lady was writing this stuff in the
1800s.
What do we have now? AI. Everyone has it
in their in their hand. A phone in their
hand. You can ask it anything and it'll
give you the knowledge of good and evil.
Spiritual evolution. The golden age is
seen as the next stage of human
evolution moving beyond the current
limitations of the material world.
Okay, that sounds a lot like
singularity, right? Like we metaverse,
like we're going into another realm, a
plane another plane of existence.
And the connection to the age of
Aquarius.
Blavatsky connects this future golden
age to the coming age of Aquarius, a
period that will be marked by a rebirth
of spiritual intelligence and intuitive
perception.
Are you catching this, guys? This is a
rebirth.
The phoenix coming out of the ashes,
right? That's what this is all about,
rebirth.
And so I asked, "What did Aleister
Crowley say about the golden age?"
According to Aleister Crowley, the
golden age refers to his early
refers to his early association with the
Hermetic Order of the Golden Dawn, a
late 19th century magical society
focused on Hermeticism and later his own
mystical system of Thelema. While Golden
Dawn was the name of the order,
Crowley's Golden Dawn
was the name of the order. Crowley's
concept of the golden age also points to
a future spiritual utopia.
And the culmination
of his philosophy of achieving personal
fulfillment through the pursuit of one's
true will and the great work. Great
work, interesting. The Hermetic Order of
the Golden Dawn. Crowley was a member of
this influential British occult society
which focused on
Renaissance magic, Kabbalah, astrology,
and tarot. His His time in the order,
though relatively brief, shaped his
early magical development. Thelema and
the great work. After leaving the Golden
Dawn, Crowley developed his own
religion, Thelema, which he saw as a
path to a new spiritual era. He believed
that the golden age would be a period
when humanity fully the principles of
Thelema, achieving self-realization by
discovering and living their true will.
This pursuit
was also referred to as the great work.
Okay.
So, where do you think these esoteric
people got this knowledge from that
they're writing about? All three of
them, Alice Bailey, Helena Blavatsky,
Aleister Crowley, all talked about the
golden age, the same words that Trump is
saying.
And what would What do they all have in
common? That it was going to be during
the age of Aquarius, which is anywhere
from 20 2020 to 2025, somewhere in that
era, where we're going to have a shift
in consciousness, that we're all going
to be more spiritual, and we're all
going to There's going to be peace and
harmony. We're all going to somehow
coexist in this one world religion.
And why? Because the externalization of
the hierarchy, the beings are actually
going to manifest. And what are we
seeing right now?
Over and over and over we're seeing on
TV, you know, Harvard scientist says
three-eyed Atlas is really uh uh
alien ship in disguise that's going to
be here soon. Over and over and over
we're hearing about these
interdimensional beings that are
communicating with us. It's only a
matter of time before literally the
government gets on television and says,
"Look, we can't hide it anymore. They're
here. They're among us. They've been
helping us for thousands of years. Do
not fear. They are our space brothers.
They're here to help us."
And eventually it's going to be uniting
us in a war against the second coming of
Christ, because that's what Revelation
says, that these
spirits like frogs are the unclean
spirits that gather the militaries of
the world
to battle against the second coming of
Christ. That's where all this is
heading.
Notice right here,
he was talking about where every single
piece of technology you own will be
seamlessly linked. That right there is
singularity.
So I asked,
>> piece of technology you own will be
seamlessly linked.
So I asked Google,
"Is Genesis Mission going to push us
towards a singularity movement?" This is
what it said.
The recently launched US government's
Genesis Mission aims to accelerate
AI-driven scientific discovery, which
could indirectly
contribute to the rapid technological
process
that some associate with the idea of
technological singularity.
All right? Like I'm telling you, Google
is the least conspiratorial answer
you're going to get. And it says, "Well,
it's not really the plan, but
it could contribute indirectly,
contribute to
a technological singularity. But the
mission's stated goals are focused on
specific national priorities, not the
singularity itself. The technological
singularity is a hypothetical future
point at which technological growth
becomes uncontrollable and irreversible,
resulting in unfathomable changes to
human civilization,
often linked to the creation of
superintelligence.
The Genesis Mission is not explicitly
designed to cause this event,
but rather to serve as an engine for
discovery
that doubles R&D predicted productivity
within a decade. Conclusion, while the
mission's
Genesis Mission official documents do
not use the term singularity, some
external commentate commentators have
noted that this significant acceleration
of AI capabilities could be seen as a
step on the path towards such a future,
or at least a reflection of the human
sprint towards the singularity. The core
aim, however, is to leverage AI for
practical, strategic
national advantages.
All right? That's where all this is
headed. Now, I want you to pay
attention, Genesis Mission.
Pay attention to this logo, all right?
This logo is very interesting. At first
I thought, "Oh man, it looks like three
sixes."
I'm not going to go there because really
there's only two if you look at it.
There's two sixes.
But what else do you see in the picture?
I see two crescent moons, call me crazy,
that's what I see. This is the Genesis
Mission logo.
When you look up a crescent moon,
the crescent moon is strongly linked to
the idea of a new age, go figure. Big
shock, right? Representing new
beginnings, Genesis, new beginnings.
Uh one world order, new beginnings,
phoenix rising out of the ashes, all
right? Change, hope, and the start of a
new cycle. This symbolism comes from the
moon's waxing phase, where it grows from
darkness into light, signifying the
emergence of a new beginning after a
period of darkness or an ending. Now,
call me crazy.
It literally looks like I copied and
pasted that on there, but this is the
picture that Google gave me.
Dude, it's the same image
to a T.
And it goes on and it says, "New
beginnings and hope. The waxing crescent
is
uh the first sliver of the moon visible
after the new moon as seen and symbol of
hope, birth, new cycle." I'm trying to
see something here. "Feminine energy."
Fourth fourth point.
"In many cultures, the crescent is
associated with the goddess and feminine
energy, symbolizing nurture, creativity,
and intuition." All right? Feminine
energy. We're all about feminism right
now. We got Chris Bledsoe, the Christian
who says that aliens are good angels. He
communicates with Hathor, the lady who
he says is the Holy Spirit. All this
stuff is coming together right now,
okay?
So, did James Cameron have a dream about
the movie Terminator? Yes. James Cameron
had a fever dream about a chrome
skeleton emerging from flames that
inspired the Terminator, okay?
Look, when
when you're not walking with God and
you're not asking,
"God, fill me with your Holy Spirit
today and give me give me your words,
not my words. Inspire me. Give me um a
vision of a movie that would just
draw people closer to you and to the
Bible." If you're not walking like that
and you're believing in things like
pantheism, you're going to be inspired
by something else. He had a dream about
Avatar. It's the number one most selling
movie of all time, Avatar.
Right under Titanic, which he also
directed. Then you got Terminator.
Terminator 2 is on that top list of
movies that was like pushed the
boundaries of its time.
This is from Little Light Studios. It's
a video that I did about Avatar. And
listen to what James Cameron said. So,
this is going back to 1976,
I think. The thing that's interesting
about it is that I've already got a a
tall, hot, blue girl in that movie. Her
name wasn't Na'vi, but I was already
thinking about it then. A lot of stuff
comes to me in dreams, and I remember
it. Sometimes I write it down. Sometimes
it's an image, and I'll go I'll go draw
or paint that image. And I quickly
painted as many of them as I could
remember.
>> One of them was a glowing forest with a
river of light running through it.
>> And trees that kind of looked like fiber
optics.
>> Well, guess what? Cut to, you know, 30
years later.
>> I'm making a movie where we're spending
>> millions of dollars to actually create
that image, but that image came in a in
a dream when I was uh 18 years old. Now,
this is interesting.
>> This is one of the first pieces of
artwork
>> that I did for Terminator, even before I
wrote it.
>> And it's the chrome skeleton coming out
of the fire. That was kind of a defining
image. That's the image that came to me
in a dream in 1981. I always think of
the the universe is like a a giant bank
vault lock, you know, and the tumblers
are constantly moving. And every once in
a while the tumblers line up and you got
to listen for the click.
All right, so I wasn't going to show
this next part,
but I do think it's a very interesting
um
there was this artist
and actually this scene this clip went
viral on Tik Tok. There was this art
teacher in the 70s this this documentary
came out in 1980,
but he said he hated God, you know, he
he cussed out God, he shut all the
windows and he said he wanted to serve
Lucifer and he said,
"I want you to show me what you look
like, so I know who I serve."
All right? That's what he said and he
said my when I was painting my hand was
doing all the motions I and it was the
best painting I'd ever done. And he
said, "I wasn't in control."
And look what this painting looked like.
Another force was physically directing
my body. Painted for several hours and
when I was finished it was the most
fantastic painting I'd ever done. And
the painting looks just like one of
those beings in the Avatar movies. Is
that not crazy, okay? James Cameron got
Avatar from a dream.
This guy said, "I want to know what you
look like, Satan."
And he painted this painting on the
left. Now, the painting on the right is
a early concept of Avatar.
Is this just fluke accident or is there
really inspiration going on?
Is James Cameron being inspired by the
very spirit that this this artist was
who said, "I hate you, God." and oh
Satan I want to know what you look like
and all this stuff, okay?
There's a research paper that predicted
that artificial intelligence will go
rogue in 2027
and lead to humanity's extinction within
a decade
is making waves in the tech world, all
right?
Very smart people
did a whole research paper where they
said and this was before
Trump was talking about this Genesis
mission, all right? I wasn't even
showing you guys the the paper.
What was it? ai-2027.com
This is the paper right here. This is
the research paper. You can read this
whole thing where they're going point by
point
year by year showing
how America would merge with China to
make the best AI there is
and this AI
would take over. It's going to It's
going to take over humanity.
And you know, these are here's polls.
Most Americans think AI will destroy
humanity someday someday. If AI attempts
to take over the world, don't count on a
kill switch to save humanity. Like
people are genuinely worried about AI
taking over humanity. It's already
smarter than us.
Okay?
I'm I'm trying not to get off track
here. Remember, Trump is announcing a
golden age.
He's announcing Genesis mission. There
was a movie that announced a new era
which golden age and new new age are the
same thing
and it was about pushing this AI that's
going to become a singularity movement.
Now, this map was on NBC News. It was
talking about all the different labs all
over the US that Genesis mission is
working with.
When you look up
what these labs do,
they do three things.
They're a part of nuclear
which in the Terminator movie movie
nuclear equaled Judgment Day because AI
became the judge of the world. AI said
humans need to be destroyed and it
launched nukes. So, that was the
Terminator prophecy in this
um predictive programming. So, some of
these locations on the map have to do
with nuclear. Some of them have to do
with particle accelerators like CERN. A
lot It's not a crazy conspiracy theory.
Many people believe that CERN is opening
up portals for the spirit world, okay?
And three is
AI surveillance which is called Stargate
by the company Oracle.
And when you add these things together,
you add the spiritual gates, you add the
surveillance
it's coming up with a stargate because a
star in the Bible represents an angel.
Not all angels are good angels, right?
So, if you make a gate for stars or for
angels, you're opening up a
dimension a portal
for demons to come in.
All these labs on this map have to do
with nuclear
particle acceleration and surveillance
AI. Very interesting. Where are things
headed?
We're about to be living in a Terminator
movie right now. The grid is being
activated. Genesis mission has begun a
week ago
and the Genesis mission links all labs.
They're linking all the labs together.
The Energy Sciences Network is the data
backbone for all this.
AI models plus robotics plus sensors
equal autonomous experimentation.
And you add AI you add Stargate AI
surveillance layer to the mix
and you got a system that watches,
predicts, controls and possibly channels
spiritual entities. Now, does that just
sound crazy? Does that sound like a
sci-fi movie? Literally, we're living in
a sci-fi movie
because we're talking about
AI
surveillance and every every device you
have is connected to one thing, one
identity, singularity, opening up
portals
with hydron colliders and all these
things.
This is crazy. The system is being set
up and the system is going to be
controlled through surveillance because
that guy said people will behave when
they're being surveillance by AI 24/7.
Judgment through AI because who's the
judge? It's not some sleeping security
guard behind a
you know, TV sets.
It's AI that's making the judgment. AI
will say, "Did you speed?" AI will say,
"I saw you litter.
You will be punished." AI will have a
criminal predictive software.
We're going to look at all your posts.
Hmm, you sound like one of those
extremist. You don't trust the
government, you homeschool your
children, you believe in Bible prophecy
is is a literal thing. Hmm, I think that
you're going to go nuts and
uh you're start a cult or something.
Predictive criminal justice.
So, surveillance will be the control.
Judgment will be through AI and
salvation will only come if you bow to
the beast system.
The counterfeit system of true worship.
There's only one true worship. Keep my
commandments. When you read Revelation,
there's three verses that says those who
keep the commandments of God will have
right to the tree of life. They're
called the the saints who keep the
commandments of God
and have right to the tree.
I don't think that's any coincidence
that the the guy who created the highest
grossing movie of all time
also has prophetic
predictive programming in his movies.
These people do not get to where they're
at because of talent. This is all people
who have sold out. They're part of the
system.
And the movies that he's most famous for
is Titanic, Avatar, Terminator and
Aliens. Isn't it interesting that this
is exactly what we're talking about in
our world today? Aliens.
And AI surveillance. It's real life.
Or I asked Google, "Was Genesis a Trojan
horse for Skynet?" And it says, "Yes.
Genesis is a Trojan horse for Skynet in
the Terminator Genesis." So, think about
this.
Maybe people didn't really like when
Trump was talking about Stargate. Maybe
they're like, "Uh we don't like that.
Total AI surveillance, total AI
governance. No, we don't like that." And
so, he changes his tune a little bit.
Genesis. We're going to roll it Genesis
mission. It's good. It's not It's not
like that Stargate stuff.
Genesis.
It's a Trojan horse
for total AI governance.
They're putting it under the guise of
oh, it's it's going to be great for the
environment. We're going to fix all the
world's problems. We're going to fix
medical conditions and electric and all
these things. We're going to cure
everything with AI.
I want you to check this movie poster
out.
This is another Terminator Genesis movie
poster different than the other one. And
what do you see happening at the bottom?
You see a city on fire.
This is the phoenix rising out of the
ashes. This is destroying the old order
and building up the new order. The
phoenix rising out of the ashes, the 9
and 11 event.
This is the lasers that destroyed cities
and replaced them with smart cities.
It's all right here in the movie poster.
And look at this. Terminator Genesis
reset the future.
Haven't we heard this term lately?
Reset the great reset, right?
Look at the imagery. This is a person in
a wheat field. That is not a
coincidence. That is not an accident.
This is total Gnosticism.
In the movie, it was all about
stopping Judgment Day. If you watch my
video on Littlelight Studios about
Terminator, you'll see that that
it was all about stopping Judgment Day.
Who wants to stop Judgment Day from
happening? Satan does.
It was a total inverted flipped movie.
And in this flyer, all this all this
poster,
you see the wheat field.
Because Jesus is going to come and
separate the wheat from the tares.
All this is so prophetic. This is just
crazy.
This whole digital ID thing is not just
being talked about in the UK.
It's being talked about right here in
America. We're not being so bold as like
they are in the UK saying, "You will
have digital ID or you will not work."
They're not saying that yet. But look
right here, digital ID and facial
comparison technology. The top of this
screen right here says
uh that this is an official website.
This is
I can't remember what it is. tsa.gov or
something like that.
And look what they're talking about. Use
your eligible digital ID at the TSA
checkpoint. Ooh, it's convenient.
All about convenience, right?
Participating states and eligible
digital IDs. Ooh, I hope we're eligible.
TSA digital IDs here. How to use TSA
digital ID.
All about the convenience. This is a
step in the right direction. You know
they got rid of the penny?
They eliminated the penny. That might
not be a big deal, but this 2025 is the
beginning of the end. We're getting rid
of money.
Everything's going digital. Everything's
going AI. Aliens are coming. They're
literally telling us that aliens we
communicate with interdimensional
beings.
And what is Trump saying? Trump's got
some interesting language.
To pursue a future of peace and security
for the world, for the whole world.
Peace.
Peace and security for the whole world
with AI surveillance, AI governance.
We have before us a rare opportunity
to bring security and stability and
peace to this region. Security and
peace. 1 Thessalonians 5:3 says, "For
when they shall say peace and safety,
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travail upon a woman with child, and
they shall not escape."
This is talking about the beast system,
the Antichrist system. It is here, guys.
If if none of this convinced you
that the beast system is being set up
right now, listen to what's coming out
of Trump's mouth.
Peace and security. Oh, well, the Bible
verse says peace and safety. Well, look
at these other translations, the
Catholic translations.
Peace and security. All four of these,
which were the only ones that showed up
on BibleHub,
all four Catholic translations literally
say verbatim peace and security.
And Trump is spitting this out of his
mouth right now.
We're entering into the golden age.
The new era, the golden age. Look, it's
going to be so great. It's going to be
peace and security. We're going to have
AI governance.
AI is going to govern everything. Isn't
that great?
We're going to be controlled by
computers.
And we're pushing into a singularity
movement.
The golden age. The golden age. What is
What do you think of when you hear gold
in the Bible?
The golden age. Think of prophetically.
Babylon rising, right?
Because in the dream that Nebuchadnezzar
had, there was this statue, a prophetic
statue of kingdoms.
And he was told by Daniel that you are
the head of gold,
O King Nebuchadnezzar of Babylon. You're
the head of gold, but you will be
conquered. And he didn't like that.
You're going to be conquered by silver,
an inferior metal.
And then by bronze, and then by iron,
and then iron and clay. You're going to
be conquered, Nebuchadnezzar. And he was
so rebellious and he hated that message
that he built an image entirely of gold
to try and prove that I am not just the
head, I'm the whole body. I'm the whole
prophetic timeline, gold.
But he did get conquered.
So, what's happening now?
Babylon is rising. We see
that Trump is trying to rebuild the
golden age,
the Babylonian
age, because Babylon was the head of
gold, right? Babylon was the head of
gold. You can see that in Daniel 2:38.
So, now let's look at Revelation,
because Revelation is our time.
And he cried mightily with a strong
voice saying, "Babylon the Great is
fallen, is fallen." This is not talking
about Babylon back in the day.
This is not talking about the Babylon
that was overtaken back back a long ago.
This is talking about our future. This
is talking about right now.
Revelation.
Wait, Babylon haven't it hasn't existed
for generations. Why is it talking about
Babylon? It's talking about the new
Babylon.
"Babylon is fallen, is fallen, and is
become the habitation of devils, and the
hold of every foul spirit, and cage of
every unclean and hateful bird.
For all nations have drunk of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication,
and the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her,
and the merchants the merchants
of the earth are waxed rich through the
abundance of her delicacies." Didn't
Elon say that we're not going to need
money?
We're not going to have jobs. We're not
going to need money. We're in a golden
age. Everybody's wealthy. Everybody's
rich. Everybody has anything they want.
Now, don't get me twisted.
Babylon
is
Rome.
Rome is the one who has everyone drunk
on the wine of her fornication, but
America joins with Rome.
America is united with Rome and is It
becomes the image of the beast.
Rome is that beast with iron teeth.
And
America builds an image
of Rome, of the beast. Look at
Washington D.C. and you'll see the dome
and the obelisk. And you look at
Vatican, you'll see the dome and the
obelisk. And how is it ultimately going
to mirror image the beast? It's going to
make laws. It's going to make a whole
system, a Babylonian system, because
Vatican is nothing but Babylon. You look
at the Pope. Look up Babylon priest,
Babylonian priest. He's dressed just
like the Pope.
The Catholic Church is a is a wicked
system. It's literally Babylonian system
veiled in Christianity.
But what is the final call?
Revelation 18:4 says, "And I heard
another voice from heaven saying,
Come out of her, out of Babylon, my
people, that ye be not partakers of her
sins,
and that ye receive not of her plagues."
So, what is this telling us right now?
What is the next thing to happen after
Babylon is rising and Babylon is falling
and all these things? The plagues are
coming.
Jesus is coming soon, but we know that a
false Messiah is soon to come next.
And I believe
I don't want to say this.
I don't want to set dates.
But I believe, according to what the
esoteric occultists are predicting, that
2027 could be a very pivotal and
deceptive year.
They're even predicting that AI is going
to completely destroy humanity
by 2027.
If movies are Satan's prophecies, which
I believe they are,
if Satan puts his prophecies in the
movies,
and Terminator really is playing out
before our very eyes,
what if
they release this whole Genesis mission
thing, which they already have. What if
AI completely takes over,
decides, "Wait a minute, humanity is the
pest of this earth, and it needs to be
destroyed."
And it starts a countdown.
Nukes will be launched in 10 days. Boop.
Boop. Boop.
Won't the whole world wake up
and say, "We need a savior. We need a
hero. We need someone to save us." And
guess who's going to come on the scenes?
Satan, as a supernatural being, will
disarm the nukes,
which we've already been told that
aliens and UFOs have been disarming
nukes.
It's going to be the perfect setup to
bring every human being on earth to
their knees, crying out, "We need a
savior." Look,
uh 9/11 didn't do it. Climate change
didn't do it. What's going to bring it?
A nuclear threat to the entire world.
And the cosmic saviors will come
in their ships
and disarm the nukes and save humanity.
And they will be hailed as gods.
"This is our god." They're doing
miracles and lying signs and wonders and
deceive. They're miracle-working devils,
the Bible says.
It says that the whole world will be
deceived by means of those miracles.
Read Revelation. It's a crazy book.
We're living in it right now. If you're
not convinced, please wake up. Pay
attention. If you like this video,
please give a thumbs up. It really helps
get this video out into the algorithm.
It's a free and simple way to support
this ministry. If you would like to
support this ministry financially
because we cannot do this without you,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got Cash App, Venmo,
Zelle, PayPal. We even have Patreon. We
got some merchandise on our store. If
you'd like to buy something, we get
about $5 per sale on there.
And if you've been giving to this
ministry, we see you. We love you and
it's because of you. We cannot do this
without you. Thank you, guys. It's the
end of the year. If you're considering
giving to a ministry and you want to
give to us, we would be ever so grateful
and it will push us to the next year so
we can keep doing this. If you'd like to
invite us to come speak at your church
and share these messages with your young
people, with your old people,
we have a way to book us on our website.
We love you. We thank you. We'll see you
next time on Candid Truth.